AND WITH PULOCK OUT OF THE  ITS.
>> Butch: THE RUSSI PASS.
>> Brendan: ANOTHER
BELLOWS IS NORY.
GETS IT ACROSS AND THE
ONE-TIMER GO.E PUCK CAME CAROME.
.
A BEAUTIFUL DEFLECTION BY A
>> Butch: ARE THEY A HUNDRED
YEARS OLD, THE TOTAL FOR THE TO.
OFF THE SKATE OF PALMIERI.
THAT WENT
BELLOWS.
BELLOWS AND NELSON WITH THEM AS
THEY COME ACROSS
WRONG LINE.
HE'S AND FIND A WAY TO
WIN THIS HOCKEY GAME AND THEN
CONTINUE IT ON IN THE LOWN AT F.
AND IT'S CARLSON, 45 O
THE SAME.
>> MARCUS JOHANSSON IN FRONT OF
THE NET.
NOT THEDEVELOPING.
HE WAS ALREADY THERE READY FOR
IT.
DEEP.U HURRYING TO
PAGEAU LOOKS TO SEE IF THERE'
PLAY.
BILLY FROM THE HALF WAHL.
PALMIERI, ANGLE AND A
LITTLE SHUFFLE PASS
GOAL.
LAST YEAR THAT WAS IN THE TOY
DEPARTMENT BUT PRETTY CLOSE,  P.
REALLY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF LENG.
THIS IS THEIR FIFTH AND SIX
POWER PLAY.
HAS IT STOLEN AWAY BY IN FOR
BARZAL.
TOOK AN EXTRA SECOND.
BAILEY, HE'S THE TOY
PALMIERI.
NOW IT'S TO